okay god I don't know where to start
I've known this lady since before
electricity she's the sweetest anyway
good evening to all of y'all and thank
you the list of pioneering
african-american artists and film
includes such distinguished names as
Michelle
McDaniel Dandridge Roberson D and Davis
Belafonte and of course party a but that
list is far from complete without the
intrusion of the indomitable
incomparable indefatigable Cicely Tyson
El Cicely said just a few years ago that
she's a firm believer in divine guidance
and that being an actor was not
something I chose to do but something I
was chosen to do well for this regal
lady the daughter of immigrants from the
West Indies who first added a church
piano and organ at the height of the
Great Depression and dreamed of faraway
places where drama and dance could move
people to feel something deeper and she
most definitely was she was chosen to
make a difference for all who would
follow in the path she cut through the
wilderness of other people's
expectations she was chosen to open eyes
to open hearts and from Angela Bassett
to Halle Berry Viola Davis Lynn
Whitfield Whoopi Goldberg the Queen
Latifah Oprah Winfrey Lupita Nyong'o the
list today is long of supremely talented
and accomplished african-american
artists who know they stand on the
shoulders of the woman who has chosen to
open those doors and film and everywhere
miss Cicely thank time yeah
and what a remarkable journey
[Applause]
Gaga certainly from Harlem till
Hollywood and they didn't happen
overnight and all my friends our honoree
did not just wake up one day and grace
us with her beautiful presence or I'm
staged on screen on television you know
The Herald history from the blacks to
the autobiography of Miss Jane Pittman
to roots I was on that the fried green
tomatoes and the help the accolades are
all inspiring Best Actress nominee in
1972 for sounder the Screen Actors Guild
Award her Tony Award her Emmy Awards he
don't never stopped and her black reel
Awards the Kennedy Center Honor
and now our nation's highest civilian
award the Medal of Freedom draped around
her neck by Barack Obama
her work grace dignity class humility
and profound professionalism firmly
placed her on the pedestal of Hollywood
royalty and now at long last I could not
be more honored to say that tonight
Cicely Tyson receives from more than
well-deserved Oscar Cicely you once said
talent is the thing that allows you to
function correctly in a given set of
circumstances she just happened to do
the right thing well for more than seven
decades what a talent you've always had
for doing the right thing we are all the
better for it we love you for it tonight
dear Sicily we salute you for it
god bless you give it up y'all
[Applause]